we got the clippers versus sons playoff
p
can't can't make his free throws again
then he did it again he had a great i
feel bad for the guys
he's playing so great but then he keeps
missing one
[ __ ] crucial free throw or two
[ __ ] crucial free throws and then the
team loses
it's really a shame because we thought
they were dead when kawhi got hurt
i think he'd win a game exactly and it's
competitive yeah and he's keeping these
games tight
so what do you think it is it's got to
be mental right yeah
it's got to be it's in your head son you
got called pandemic pete
what [ __ ] nickname that was yeah
that's gotta eat away at you
i never thought he was that clutch but
now it's like
he plays so well for 46 minutes
paul george makes me appreciate giannis
antetokounmpo
why is that giannis has this
this like uh playful
child-like energy about the game yeah
where
i don't think he gets nervous i don't
think giannis gets nervous though
he was missing free those two he always
misses for those that's not yeah but he
was joking about it
around about it in practice he's like uh
game seven
i missed free throw i come down the full
court uh
like he just i drew a ball off my foot
he's just like saying all these things
just giggling
but after missing a free throw he'll
come down the next position and dunk on
your [ __ ] head
right and i don't think he has that
maybe he doesn't
like he's got the goldfish memory yes
but maybe it's
a a cultural thing because basketball
wasn't as valued
in his culture growing up right like i
wonder if he was playing soccer or
something and knew
how much like his country was behind him
if it was a a euros game or a world cup
game
right but with basketball it's just like
oh this is a fun game i play nobody
cares about this in greece like this is
i really like it but this is a game
whereas like playoff p
is playing for his reputation right
every second of that game he knows when
he steps up to that free-throw line
they're like they don't think i'm
playoff p
yeah and then he misses one [ __ ] i'm not
yeah he needs away at you it just [ __ ]
there's some people
giannis is peyton manning no no
eli manning okay you know how they would
say like eli's too dumb to get nervous
yeah
like he's just like all right whatever
i'm silly i kind of have an underground
that's right
yeah so i'm just gonna throw it see what
happens he'll probably come down with it
right that's janice's attitude about the
game and it's so beneficial for the
playoffs because he can have a horrible
game he can air ball free throws but
come down and get in that ass still
and i don't know if i don't know if paul
george has it you know who i think is
going to win it all
yeah i think this is chris paul's year
dude i don't even want to jinx him i'd
be excited i don't want to jinx i don't
yeah it'd be great because we've
you know we've [ __ ] on him but like it'd
be great to see him get one it would but
i think
he's the guy that's to steady his hand
at the end of a game of all the people
left yeah they're up 3-1
then we play the bucks the bucks fall
apart they give away games in ways it's
just like
how the [ __ ] you've managed to do that
yep they won last night but
so many like the first game played
against brooklyn in game five they blew
it yeah
and then also phoenix has deandre ayton
and that's
one thing when giannis is driving the
lane that's the one guy i think could
give him problems maybe in the league
deandre ayton is the unsung hero of that
phoenix scene
yeah it is amazing that he doesn't have
an ego yet where he's like i need the
ball
the guy's averaging a double double
double he got 22 boards i think last
game
he is ben wallace but with better
offense yeah and wow he is getting 22
points
not off of let me do post plays stop the
i think putbacks
alley oops different type of plays where
he's in the rhythm of the offense
he's really deferential to to
cp3 he said he's the most important
person he's ever met in his career his
most impactful best thing
ever happened in my career was and he it
is just the perfect
combination because usually a guy that's
that good on a team with chris paul
beefs with chris paul yeah and they
can't get along but because he's so
young
that's the difference they love they
didn't have problems with him in okc
because they're all babies
so they're looking at chris paul deonton
said he's like a big brother
like there but there's like a 12 13 year
age difference so of course you feel
that if it's a three four year age
difference it's like bro shut the [ __ ]
up
devin booker throw 24 deandre 1822 chris
paul 37 i think 36
that's a big gap so you're going to look
at that guy like he's a big brother yeah
and chris paul said they've had some
tense moments and like they've been
upset at each other
but that's big brother yep i'm better
because of him so this is the per
and apparently chris paul wanted to come
to phoenix yeah he kind of was like i
want to go there yeah and dog he was
right i'm telling you that eight in bro
aidan the way he plays defense the way
he rebounds 22 rebounds alone
let's say 10 of those are offensive
that's changes again
10 possessions where you have another
chance to score
10 that's that's just people don't
realize offensive rebound is a steal
yeah it's the same thing yeah
effectively not only is it a steal
you're already on that side and you can
probably get put back basket even easier
yeah offensive rebound leads one pass to
wide open jump shooter like the
offensive rebound is so
[ __ ] impactful can change again
that's 20 point difference in a game
where they won by what four points yeah
10 offensive boards if it was a 10 i'm
not exactly sure how many
but that is the game changer right there
yeah yeah okay i had a game-winning
alley-oop
in the playoffs i don't know if that's
ever happened yeah game-winning alley
from an inbounds play crazy
you